we're talking discovery here not
admissibility you may disclose it and
none of it's admissible
because there's nothing in it for
example if they give opinion a
on the stand and there's a transcript in
another case they said not a
that's permissible impeachment of their
opinion to go in and say well
in state versus smith didn't you say
x y and z and now you're saying abc
i think that's permissible impeachment
and if you have transcripts
i think uh discovery wise uh mr nelson's
entitled to them
but what i'm saying is until that
witness says not
a on the witness stand that prior
doesn't
i may be mixing up the court's analogy
until that witness says hey on the
witness stand
not a isn't a statement about the case
correct potential impeachment
okay so there's no duty to disclose that
until he says until he says hey i'm
telling you to disclose it
and then i assume the court will be
telling the defense to do that as well
absolutely if you have transcripts of
somebody's
the other side's witnesses or your own
those should be disclosed
this is in federal court where you have
to wait till cross-examination
your honor that is all of the defendants
motions we
were prepared to address today there are
several of our emotions that we could
address i don't know if the court wants
me to
build the podium or start in on those
[Music]
is there can we talk about number 33 the
spark of life or did you want to wait
for later
i would prefer to wait your honor that's
fine
i mean sparking life is a very weird
to all uh i just i'm hesitant to start
into it today
because i'm not sure what the contours
that defense council is thinking of
with regard to sparky life testimony to
me it's forward but
i'm just not sure i know exactly what
the
problem was there so i didn't talk did
not talk about it ahead of time and
all right why did you let the two of you
talk and we can address it later
i mean this yeah okay
okay all right
so it's my understanding that the other
defense motions
have not been addressed today we will
address
do you want me to start on hours or do
you want to nelson are you prepared to
on the stage yes all right
and if you could
reference the i will assume
on the state's motions that
these are from the oceans
[Music]
february 8th 2021
unless you tell me otherwise that's my
uh that's what i'm looking working from
your honor
all right and uh
these are also numbered so if we can
walk through the numbers and
let's start with things that are not
contested
i actually think that the vast majority
of these will not be contested your
honor okay
um with respect to witness number one or
excuse me motion number one we have no
objection
as to the permissible um bounds
impeachment
would not use a fbi report or a bca
report to impeach a witness who didn't
prepare
that statement number two is one that is
going to be
is going to be contested it also
corresponds to a subsequent filing
that i don't have pulled up right now
but number two will be contested
i think that you're talking about the
state's second amendment
correct that were filed on march 4th is
that correct mr frank
understood thank you mr nelson thank you
uh motion number three your honor i
think is premature i think that goes to
the questions
of jury instructions obviously would not
make any reference to any rules of law
that would not were not contained within
jury instructions
but because we have not had a jury
instruction conference yet
i think
mr frank would you agree with that and i
actually need you
i need a microphone by you
[Music]
the problem i have with waiting of
course is we will have
vardir we will have jury we will have
opening statements and witness testimony
that could
depend on what these concepts
are and what they're going to be so i
don't think this is something we can
reserve until the end of trial
when we're looking at the final jury
instructions because as
part of our motion is you know any
testimony or argument about
essentially incorrect standards of law
so i do think we need to address this
certainly before opening statements
well again my strong position is nobody
should be
trying to instruct the jury on the law
because that's my job at the end of the
case
um and so if council starts to ask
jurors their opinions about
what does this charge mean and use words
like but four or n 10
that's going to be problematic in jury
selection just to warn you but mr nelson
uh
you do you have any and do you object to
these or what part do you object to
no i don't necessarily object to them
your honor i just think that in terms of
what the appropriate legal standards are
has not been
we have not thought about about those
for lack of a better term um and so in
that regard your honor
it's not my customary practice to
inquire as to the
law or the rules of law in voidir um
and i rarely ever reference any sort of
element in an opening so i mean it
wouldn't be my intention
number one or if the court wants to
grant it subject to
a jury instruction conference later
that's fine too i think that's the best
way to
handle it i'm going to grant it subject
to the jury instruction conference
because i assume the state is re relying
on the substantial factor in causing
death
correct and you know we did submit a
memorandum
that addresses this motion too and
i think everyone is in a safe harbor if
you rely on the jury instruction guides
for elements
uh generally
um and so if these aren't in the jury
instruction guides you are in dangerous
waters
so i'll grant it with the with the
understanding that we'll talk about it
at our
jury instruction conference sounds good
your
number i'm just looking at address that
later in the week
okay number five i think is
very similar to the one of our
jury instructions i have no objection to
that your honor
number six i think is uh
is also um
part of our ongoing discussions about
the training materials that both sides
intend to
introduce and the reasons for which they
may be introduced
uh whether it be show that mr shroven
particular training
or policies of the mpd and so
that's just a discussion that we're
continuing to have i think we've made
some substantial progress in that regard
and so
just asking to reserve it and if we need
to come back to that at a later time
any objection to reserving it mr frank
all right that's reserved
number seven um i have no objection to
that your honor
okay
without objection eight no objection
granted without objection not uh it's
nine ten are identical and they are also
identical to one of the defense martials
according
to this i think we've already
established that you're not going to
comment on each other's failure to call
a witness
and if the answer to that was to call
400 witnesses if this would not be a
four-week trial
go ahead uh 11
again uh in terms of i believe that the
court has already issued its ruling on
all 404 b
stuff so it would be no objection to
that other than subject to
rio
number 12
again um this i have generally no
objection to this however
the state has agreed to provide me with
the
criminal convictions of witnesses and if
there is any intent to
to use any prior criminal convictions we
can cross that bridge
should we learn about it
i'll essentially reserve that okay and i
believe that's all their emotions
mr frank anything else we have the
second supplemental but that was
basically the
reserving on the expert right just
because
we obtain additional information from
the first the time of the first motion
to
the second amendment all right
so i didn't count them up but we've got
a handful of motions left to argue more
uh substantively is that correct
i'll try and identify them myself but uh
that's it for today then as far as
motions
other than stipulations just distracts
for costs yeah uh who wants to
if somebody wants to take the podium and
for the record again uh over the
mid morning and early afternoon break uh
council for
the defense state matt and fern and dude
agreed upon jury strikes we are
in agreement to strike juror numbers 5
for cause juror number 11
for cause 12 13
14 15
18 22
24 25
32 35
45 47
and 50. we only made it through the
first 50 right now that's fine that
helps us a lot
as far as who to call in let me make
sure i've got it correctly
five 11 12
13 14 15
16 18 22
24 25 32
35 45 47
and 50. is that correct state agreed
all right based on the stipulation i'll
we'll release those people um
for cause
since i think the parties are obviously
being very
thoughtful about the proper use of our
time injury selection by
identifying these ahead of time i may
reduce the number of jurors we bring in
from 16
to possibly 12 or 14.
the last trial we did in here in january
which was
murder in the first degree case we were
pretty
pretty good at keeping six processions
six in the morning six in the afternoon
and getting to everybody so i'm thinking
this one we might be able to get
there might still be cause challenges
that are be granted
so my thoughts are seven and seven but
if you have any advice to the court on
that i'm happy to
to hear from anybody so but i think for
now we'll go with seven and seven
all right is there anything else for the
record today ah you can't do it
all right anything further mr nelson
all right we are in recess uh tomorrow
the jury has been ordered to report at 8
30.
uh and so we'll try and get started with
jury selection
by nine if we have motions at eight so
we will come back at eight
the jury is expected to start with
selection at nine
and i'll start that with the basic
group discussion or instructions before
we go one by one
as i've said to the state unless the
court of appeals tells me otherwise
we're going to keep moving so with that
uh we're adjourning until 8 am tomorrow
thank you all
stuff on the table though that's a
defensiveness
great so do i just leave this
uh here yup i'll come and pick it up
because i'm gonna come along
how's the face how can you tell how's
the audio coming across
from
yeah so i'm glad it's coming across on
their feed but i'm going to call andy
come up and see if they can adjust that
because i thought it was pretty soft
okay so there could be audio there could
there could be jurors you know back
especially david behind so
you